[Music]
are you happier than ever we have a
sweet baby boy and our marriage is going
so well I mean I think every duck is in
its row
Sean and Catherine Lowe met on The
Bachelor and four years later they're
celebrating three years of marriage
being new parents and their new
furniture line but it's taken a lot to
get them to the best place of their
lives ET sat down with the pair
exclusively at their Dallas home what
about the hard times what hard times
have there been for you I think the
first year marriage is not a moment but
it is hard those adjustments plus coming
updates on the Stars and moving into a
city I didn't know he went from The
Bachelor to Dancing with the Stars which
was really I didn't know the time
commitment I was signing up for when I
decided to do that show and you know I
was rehearsing 10 or 12 hours a day so
my new fiance was basically just on her
own which was really unfair to her but
Sean says it was that struggle that
confirmed he'd proposed to the right
woman you know being able to work
through that and the challenges that you
face cuz we barely knew each other when
we got engaged to be able to overcome
that giant hurdle I really felt like
yeah there's there's no doubt about it
she's the one well now nick is doing it
he's doing Dancing with the Stars what
advice do you maybe have for him and
have you shared any of that advice with
him
no I haven't shared any advice with him
I would say you know your free time is
limited on Dancing with the Stars and
every chance you get just make sure
you're spending it with Vanessa given my
experience I would say it's probably
healthier if you just skipped it but
with that said I can't fault anyone for
doing it I did it I was an average guy
who was approached and they said hey
we'll give you a bunch of money if you
want to dance and I thought that I mean
sounds fun sounds easy and I'm an
average guy who could use a bunch of
money don't do it
[Music]
you